[Musique]
archives tiré de la campagne
présidentielle de 74 ou un candidat
septuagénaire des jackass le ronron
politique pour nous alerter sur des
dangers futur
[Musique]
vous savez ce qui va se passer eh bien
nous allons bientôt manquer de l'eau et
c'est pourquoi je bois devant vous un
verre d'eau précieuse puisque avant la
fin du siècle si nous continuons un tel
débordement elle manquera à lundi je
vous dis au revoir et j'espère vous
revoir pour vous expliquer notre projet
global d'avenir merci mais hallyday
rené dumont pionnier de l'écologie
politique
yannick jadot pourquoi nos sociétés ont
elles mis si longtemps à prendre cette
cause au sérieux parce que c'est
difficile parce que c'est difficile de
se projeter dans un avenir qui peut être
catastrophique si on n'agit pas parce
que c'est toujours difficile de changer
ses comportements parce qu'on a des
habitudes on a des conforts et surtout
si on a l'impression qu'au fond
si le voisin le fait parce que c'est
vraiment utile si la france le fait
parce que c'est vraiment grave et on
peut reporter comme ça les américains
qui dit si les chinois ne font pas
pourquoi nous le faire et que ça
s'inscrit dans le temps donc ce qu'il
faut arriver à faire aujourd'hui c'est à
démontrer que à la fois changer ses
comportements
c'est se faire du bien c'est nous faire
du bien collectivement mais
changer ses comportements ça suffit pas
c'est un quart de la réponse embraye
115% ce que les trois quarts de la
réponse sont les politiques publiques
donc on voit rené dumont dans l' alerte
évidemment aujourd'hui l'enjeu c'est de
prendre le pouvoir c'est de prendre le
pouvoir sortir du déni mais pour sortir
du déni il faut créer d'entousiasme à la
fois répondent concrètement dire le
chemin et dire que tout le monde sera
sur ce chemin là que ça se fera d'abord
bénéfice des des plus fragiles victime
de du dérèglement climatique victimes de
la pollution de l'air victimes de la
malbouffe et que ça se fera d'abord à
leurs bénéfices et non pas à leur
détriment
[Musique]